- I love though that you
also promote body positivity.
You have a campaign, a
movement, called I Weigh, right?
- Yeah, it's a body neutrality movement.
(applause)
- So why is this important to you?
- So I Weigh is a body
neutrality movement,
it's about getting away from
thinking about your body,
and instead thinking about
the things in your life
that you should be grateful for.
Like, I weigh the sum of all my parts,
I weigh, like, you can't measure my worth
on a weighing scale, you can't
measure your own like that.
It's insane that we still do this to women
in this day and age, so
it's about, like, you know,
I weigh my relationship,
my contribution to society,
my financial independence, my activism,
that's what I weigh, that's my worth.
And so it's a movement.
(applause)
- That is very cool.
- It's this whole global movement,
where we have almost a million followers,
and we get five or 6,000 more a day,
of people from everywhere,
from all walks of life,
who are just tired of being undermined
and underestimated by society.
And it's this really beautiful space
that I'm launching into
a company next year,
and we're gonna take
this as far as we can.
And we're changing laws
and changing global policies together,
and we're just done
with how we treat women.
- I think it's important,
because, I think
sometimes we focus so much
on the aesthetics of
what health looks like,
instead of what actual health,
like and what's going on inside your body,
and we just don't know, you know?
So it's like, what's going
on in someone's life,
so I think it's a really
important thing you're doing,
especially because you have
such a big spotlight on you.
So thank you, for doing that.
- Thanks, you've been
through some body shaming.
- I have no idea what you're referring to.
I literally am getting
trolled right now online.
- That's so wild, but I
remember you going through that,
and then very shortly afterwards,
I gained a lot of weight back in England.
I was a radio DJ, by the way,
you couldn't even see me,
people just wanted to know I
was thin over the airwaves.
So I got nationally fat
shamed for like six months
in my own country, and it
was your response to yours
that gave me the strength
to get through mine.
- Did I use a word that
I can't say on this show?
- Yeah.